well hello you know I felt like it'd be a bit awkward because like the official start is actually at 10 a.m.
but like we're supposed to have a waiting room for 30 minutes I feel like it'd be awkward to have you guys just watch this for 30 minutes so hello I decided to warn you guys up yeah we still got we still got 25 I I feel like it'd be a bit weird to have you guys just watched this for 25 minutes.
That's why I'm here.
I'm here.
I'm here to hang out.
Hang out before...
Well, I mean, technically, this is still sponsored dokey.
But we'll hang out for, I guess, 25 more minutes before sponsor, sponsor dokey is there.
Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
I want to say first off, thank you to PUBG for sponsoring this stream.
But yes, if you guys want to help out this stream, you can see...
scan this QR code and do a survey.
Apparently there's a lot of stuff.
It's about like what you guys feel about this game from watching the stream.
So like after the stream or even like during the stream.
Maybe you guys can do the survey scan this code or click on the link pinned in my chat.
It does help out a lot.
You see me looking to my left is because that's where you guys are.
My third monitor.
My third monitor doesn't work.
Wait, because the command's not working.
My staff said they set up the commands, but let me double check real quick.
But yes, we only have one mod today.
So let me double check.
Did they...
Oh, you know what they did?
You know what they did, Silent?
They put it on my YouTube nightbox.
That's why it's not working.
They put it on my YouTube Nightbot because I have two Nightbots.
So, I think this is.
Let me double check.
Wait.
Oh, JK.
I lied.
It's my Twitch one.
Ha, JK.
They just forgot to do the command.
Oh, wait.
Oh, JK.
Um, JK.
Um, they just put in.
It's, it's, we're actually on my Twitch one.
I'm sorry.
It's so confusing when I have two Nightbots.
Uh, it's so confusing.
Okay, um, it's just silent use the wrong goddamn command.
I can't swear by the way to stream It's a rollercoaster guys.
It's 930 JK to that JK.
It's just my mind use the wrong command.
So it messed with me It messed with me.
It's on my phone
It's it's never the streamers fun
I'm JKception No, no, no It's never my fault So yes, it used the Command exclamation point PUBG But yes, it's not the usual PUBG game It's actually a new game Into the PUBG series So it's a top Down tactical shooter So you know how like when you have to like I mean,
they have different modes.
They have Team Deathmatch.
Also, the usual one where you have to plan a bomb or use the bomb.
And then when you're in defense, it's like you have to fortify walls.
You know, like those types of top-down tactical shooters.
Like, you have to fortify walls.
And then you can breach.
Like breaching.
And then, boom.
I'll show you guys.
We don't have to show the tutorial.
But I'll show you guys the tutorial.
So you guys give the sense.
I mean, I have like...
We have an hour...
before like we get into the discord to do the 2v2 so i'll show you guys the tutorial because i'm not as well you know like show you guys the gameplay of it um um but yeah no i i tried it out in tutorial and we did like custom games to like try get our feeling good but there's like different characters and stuff like different characters give like different utils um so like one character can have like uh okay like during like rehearsal like it's oh my gosh like so i'll be team up moxie um we're gonna 2v2 and i'm a little bit i'm a little bit nervous i'm a little bit shy but anyway uh moxie wasn't there for the tech rehearsal so it was just me versus two other people and like it was like you know versus the other two streamers and like it was just like i would kill one and then the other person would just have a shotgun i'm like what do i do and they just like i'm like i did it i got i got my one but i had to get two I kill it and it's like pop pop and when I've been pop pop it was like
pop and then I'm dead I got I got I got to get my twos not get my one
um um yeah so like literally just pop and I'm dead I was like I got shotgun
it's a very um i i got it okay then you think i could defense defend a 1v2 i just they just run at me i was just i was just like whatever like attack was a lot attacking maybe i almost i almost got at least one point in attacking like um i didn't know my camping spots yet like you know how like dirt used usually in defusal and defense and offense like when you're doing defense um um it's all about like finding the spot to camp so that no one will but it's i feel like it's a little bit more um you have to be more tactical a bit when it's you know a tactical shooter um because like um because it's a top down so like i feel like you gotta figure out like use your head to be like which one which one um which would be the easiest like spot that like the ash can't see in a top down scenario but also didn't have that you know they were two so they could just they threw in the sonar and it did it did it they just threw in a sonar into that room i was like oh yes i die i they know where i am
But I've tried my best.
But like I said, it's third person, because it is top down.
So it's like a top view.
So there's a lot of strategies.
There's a lot of weapons.
Like I said, there was like SMGs.
There was sniper shotgun.
There was like grenade launcher.
There was like a top.
One of the characters gave like toxic gas or something.
And then because I was trying to use that in the 1V2.
It sort of worked, dude.
I just threw in toxic gas.
they couldn't see so it sort of worked you know um oh it's search and destroy i forgot what it's called it's basically called search and destroy so you know um there's team death match and um just hide bro there's team death match and search and destroy so you know like usually like the strategic uh play um in the usual like compared to traditional fps games and um um and i apparently you can see what your teammates are seeing um uh through the third third person view so it that's like you know that's a lot easier because when you're first person you don't really know where people are there is a ping system so i could be like there they are uh so yeah so it's very easy um for me it was very easy to get into i just like you know it's very simple and direct uh but yes again thank you again to pubg for the sponsor and if you could scan the qr code or click on the link uh link pinned in my chat and do the survey that will help the stream out a lot and help uh um help out pubg blind spot um
also um we're technically i think we're broadcast at twitch con i think uh let me double check i could be like saying stuff on my ass right now technically the sponsor doesn't start until until 20 minutes this is a bonus it's technically we could just like run the starting soon uh and room um but i was just like you know i just want to hang out uh just want to hang out with you guys um but yes uh i believe it's let me double check just to be sure i'm not like you know lying
oh yes oh they broadcast it maybe they start broadcasting at 10 a.m but like um they have the They have a booth at TwitchCon at the moment.
So, um, we might be broadcast, um, at the booth itself as well.
Um, so, you know, you guys can say hi.
Okay, well, not right now, because I didn't, I forgot.
I didn't put you guys, um, I didn't put you guys on the screen right now, because it's the starting screen.
Um, but, like, you guys can say hi later.
You can say hi later when we swap screens.
Uh, but yeah, there was a lot of characters to choose from.
I like the artwork.
It's where it's pretty neat There was a I was, there was so many characters I didn't know which one to pick I guess I should pick the one with a shotgun Because I feel like, I don't know Unless I get a goddamn deagle headshot From 20 miles away I feel like,
because like I feel like since it's a tactical shooter Like, you're always going to be close up You know, not like Not like far away So I have to be like super close up with someone so i feel you know if someone's gonna be breaching my walls like be like say hello to my shotgun pop pop um but only like certain characters uh carry shotgun so it'll be it'll be interesting to see i'm just gonna make sure you know i'll use this time to read through like um Make sure I don't miss out on anything
But yeah, I had to wake up super early Actually, okay, you know, I didn't I'm sorry, I still, I didn't You know how I was like, I'm going to get my I'm going to get my life together yesterday I went straight to bed
You know, to be fair, I did hydrate first
I was I was so okay to be fair I wanted to do some little some little rinkeroos at first but then I was just like I should sleep I knew if I get started on some rinkeroos um I would not wake up so I did get my life together I technically technically I did get my life together if you think about it because I technically did go to sleep early.
I actually went to sleep early.
A whole one in the morning early.
No, I did.
I slept at one in the morning.
That is so early for me.
If you think about it in the East Coast, that would have been like four in the morning.
So I technically stayed up on the other side of the world.
I live on the West Coast, but technically if you think about it, my soul is still in New York City.
But to be fair, I had to get up.
I actually woke up naturally at 8 in the morning.
Wait, was it?
At like, I think 8 in the morning, I naturally woke up.
I don't say I got really worried because I didn't set up any alarm.
And I was like, I'll let my body decide my face.
I like to do a little gamble and be like, my body will decide.
If I wake up in time for the sponsor,
my body will figure it out.
It's the risk, you know, the risk of it.
Yeah, my body chooses my fate today.
That's a bold strategy.
So I was just like, that's it.
What a power.
But it worked.
It worked.
I woke up at 8 in the morning.
The great spirit guides my hand.
See, I am in control of my life.
The thrill of the gotcha.
Waking up or not.
You're so...
Okay, it's because I believed in myself, guys.
I believed in myself.
I knew my body won't betray me.
I had fate.
You just gotta believe in yourself.
And it worked.
I was here on time.
I made it.
I made it in everything.
I still don't know what to stream after.
I'm still trying to figure it out.
Oh yeah, no.
When Dad comes back.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'll continue streaming something on Twitch.
Or if I...
um if i'll uh go on because i don't know what to say because you know how i was gonna figure it out after yesterday's stream but then i was like you know i didn't figure it out i just went straight to bed oh he comes back on sunday i i was like you know i said i was like something came up i can i i pick him up on sunday and they did no questions asked they didn't ask any questions
another another little thing I want to say but thank you again to puppy for the sponsor um this was like uh for me um I had to like like everything was finalized for me for this sponsor like I think like yesterday or like day before yesterday um um so that's why like everyone's like whoa what you guys sponsored to be fair I am um um I say I always say I say yes to a lot of stuff because
but it's interesting it's pubg too so um it'll be i thought it would be really interesting because it is also um pubg um and um and is a new game in the franchise um i think we do have other pubg games i wonder um other than the pubg other than pubg um but uh i thought it'd be interesting because it is i don't play a lot of tactical shooters i don't play a lot especially like top i don't know i don't i usually don't play a lot of tactical shooters so it'll be very interesting but it is top down so i figured like you know i could see more so i don't get camped out more in other tactical shooters so like that's what i'm hoping for um if we get absolutely shit on then like that's all right you know that's on us that's that's on us but like you know um uh how how me and moxie would do um apparently later on uh viewers would be able to join us later i don't know if it'd be like viewers at twitch con or uh you like viewers here in our chat um but there is a 4v4 later uh so i'm not unsure
right now if it's like 4v4 with you guys like the people in the chat um because it the game isn't out yet the game isn't out yet so i'm unsure at the moment but uh i think we're gonna be uh is it like is it can you is there early access let me double check um let me double check uh pub g blind spot let's see oh yeah yeah so uh yeah it's a new game um so um i'm not sure how at the moment how viewers would be able to i suppose it is with people now it's a San Diego go to the poopy like guys we see you guys still have time you have an hour and 10 minutes to get to San Diego TwitchCon and to play with us getting on the place mama need a hurry I didn't get there in an hour and in 20 minutes I can play with my OSCE and I'm just wait please just wait a bit
Do you think I'll make it from Amsterdam?
I think it's possible.
I think if you buy it, if you get on the plane within the next 30 minutes, I think that's like close enough, right?
San Diego is like an hour away from Amsterdam.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm not very good at geography, but that seems right.
Astro World, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
yeah if you run really really fast then maybe you can make it uh it was a geology uh and i don't know i don't i almost said like out of geology and geology i had to like stop myself i was like is that the right word uh oh yes but yes please feel free to scan the qr code um and do the survey maybe i don't you might not have the content i haven't seen the survey yet but you might not have the actual context of like the questions in the survey because we haven't technically started yet so uh please please don't lie in the survey because the survey link is linked to me so if you lie in the survey or say some dumb shit like it it links to me so they'll know it's they'll know you came from me don't know you came from my stream because each streamer gets his own unique link chat we know turkey made me do it uh whoopsity um um i mentioned you in the survey they'll never find out it's from you so they'll be like yeah i was watching um i was watching moxie stream but um but like i i got like um
i became a turkey bird watcher after the stream or something so now i'm doing her survey uh uh thanks for definitely not gonna please don't oh yeah And if you do the survey, you have a chance to win a $50 steam code.
$50.
$50 American dollars.
Imagine how much that is in other currency.
Imagine that $50 dollars.
But don't convert it to Euro.
like it's like or pounds because then it's less um
yeah as long as you don't convert it to euros or pounds we should be good uh but in like my canadian monopoly money um it's a lot
uh let's see we have oh my god there he missed pass by so fast we have like three more minutes before I'll show you guys oh yeah we're we're I'll be showing you guys a couple of videos and also I'll show you guys the tutorial because like I said we have like a lot of time until we have to do the group matches and the team matches so um so I'll show you guys the tutorial so you get a sense of the game as well because I'm like like I have an hour before I think it's an hour before we get into the team matches but it's gonna be like 2v2 so me and moxie versus um emin and sunny and then uh um and then after that it's 4v4 i think it's 4v4 let me double check yeah it's team death match and then a casual match against like uh other like other people and then uh and then after that we have um we have viewer participation so so we have we people joining from the audience i assume it's at twitch gone because like i said um i i don't i it's it's not out yet the game isn't out so we're giving you
guys a preview of what the game looks like um so this is like you know this is not really my first reaction um because i did check out the tutorial already and i did we did do like some practice games um so i sort of know like the basic i am trying to figure out like what i would like to do with a camera because it's actually really like three different camera systems one is manual because it's a top down one is like it follows your crosshair it follows your mouse movement and the other one is like it follows your like cross like when you're aiming down sight so um so like i have no i've been like bouncing between the one where i aim down sight where the camera moves when i aim down sight versus manual and i don't know manual like it's a lot more work yes it is third person it is third person i'm a little Because like,
I've The only times I've interacted with Moxie Was in a group scenario Group scenario so like, we're going to have Like, we're going to Like, I don't know, I'm always so nervous, you know Whenever, like I have to interact with someone new That's when we have to have like a group discussion To about this Game.
So like, I'm just I'm just an introvert So I hope I hope like, you know I hope Moxie Doesn't think doesn't think I'm too silly I hope I'm not cringe that's it it's always the back of head oh god I hope I'm not cringe too late so um um so yeah I'm I'm a little okay I'm really nervous I'm always anything cringe don't do oh oh it's 10 all right all right it's 10 let's go solo gaming oh you see that the qr code is right there now all right let me uh let me make sure also um our sound guys sound team um isn't available so we have a mod that's gonna be a temporary sound guy for us today so good luck because you're also going to handle the discord stuff too but again thank you again for pubg for this sponsor i really appreciate it um we're gonna be checking out the i'll show you guys the tutorial because you know we still have like uh like i said before uh we do have quite a bit of time before we go into like the actual games itself um so sound guy let me know about the sound uh you are
modded now so you can tell me and i might miss your chat his his reply just just like reply to him be like here so like the entire sound team um and the other minds are currently unfortunately not here so this is his first very his first big boy job to sound balance um a sponsor stream um yes like i said it is third person so let me let me grab real quick bump bump bump all right so here you see pubg blind spot i'll show you guys the characters like i said there's like there's um apex so like you can see oh my gosh you can't see i was like as you guys can see it is util oh sorry oh wait oh nice cactus is here too um um i was told that uh outlaw was gonna be the only mod there so like that's good to know that there is another um but as you guys can't see let me let me like here you go um here you go i'll i'll disappear for a second so you guys can see there's like you know um there's like different um different types of uh weapons and utile that each character has i don't i don't know i
feel like whichever one has the shotgun would be the best one so like goldberg red chip amplifier um increasing their move oh this is like a movement boost your sticky bomb okay that's not a shotgun there's explosive hammer um this is early access by the way so things could change obviously um yeah they all have like set util so um this guy looks cool this guy looks like uh looks like a um you know like a spy villain uh there's patch she's cute i like her not because she has cat okay because she has cat girl ears it is absolutely because of it yeah um i tried using her but like the med kit took so to be fair i was 1v2ing so the med kit took so long to deploy so i think if i had you know an actual teammate it would have been a lot easier but i'll show you guys i'll show you guys a tutorial so um So this is the one thing so you can see like I can this is manual camera So I'm like trying to figure out I want to do manual because like when I aim The camera doesn't move so like I set the so
it's just that But like But like then there's like okay this one I did not like this one was like it's too much So whenever you move your mouse because I feel like it moves way too much like I don't get motion sickness but I don't like this type I personally didn't like this camera um just because like it's just too much movement and um but then there's also this one so I'm debating between this or this one where um we don't move the camera but when you aim down sight you move the camera so like I don't know I don't know which one I would do um I have no idea yet because like both of them are are like but then feel like it's gonna mess up my aim maybe um so like i'm gonna try i don't know i'll do manual for now because like for rotating my camera it's my middle mouse button so like it doesn't seem that natural is there hipfire uh no there is and you have to aim downside um so you also change from headshot with your mouse you can rebind anything um i think more consistent will be
better.
That's the thing I don't know.
I don't know which is good.
Um, I don't know what would be a good camera to use.
Okay, and then here you can aim, you shoot the feet below.
I'll re-bind in my control.
So the thing you see on the, you see on tutorial is like different.
Uh, but yeah, I'm not sure, honestly.
Maybe I should.
Should I use this?
I'll try this.
I re-binded everything.
Alright, and then we got...
Breach!
I'm breaching!
Okay, I'm reloading.
But re-bind the key.
I don't know which key to re-bind, though, for the camera.
That's the thing.
I have no idea which would be good to re-bind.
Because this is me on...
Let's see.
Aim low to breach.
Oh, yeah.
I'm breaching.
Also, I could just do this.
I just made it I'm too lazy But it teaches you about mailing and stuff
A thumb button Oh that's true Wait that is true Wait maybe I rebutted it to the thumb Okay Um where's the camera Align Rotate camera Where's my other Oh wait that's my aim low Fuck I use this to aim low So I don't know Maybe I have to readjust my controls then um i feel like i should use it for aim though let's see uh i'll do that and then i have to redo my aim look what the fuck do i sorry what the heck do i what the heck do i do for aim my bad it's pg 13 you get one um technically i get zero but Technically,
I can't see her.
PG-13, you get one.
Wait, where's the aim low, but aim down briefly?
Then what do I do for aim down briefly?
I guess I could try...
See?
I'll do that.
Apply.
Okay.
Wait, I should...
I feel like when will I ever shoot feet?
I don't know.
That's the thing.
When will I ever have to shoot the feet?
I don't know.
I still don't know which one I want to do.
Okay, so here's me barricading.
And then there's the hammer.
Breaching!
Oh!
There we go.
Breaching again!
Oh!
Alright.
And then...
Oh yeah, grenade.
So...
Grenade.
Grenade out.
There ya.
All right.
And then I can change it if I just do scroll.
Grenade out.
Where's my grenade?
It said grenade.
Oh, there it is.
All right.
Breaching!
Boom!
What am I- I don't think I can use it on people.
I don't- I haven't tried it yet, but I mean, it'll be fun to see.
If I can- Oh.
If I can use it on people.
Is there like, oh there's like a cool down, a small cool down?
Because I tried to use it on this guy, but it didn't work.
JK, it worked.
Okay, the goal is to use the hammer on some, this is the goal.
We have a new goal.
I don't care if we lose.
I don't care if we lose, we gotta use the hammer on someone.
up someone will be stupid oh shit someone will be stupid enough oh no i feel like the hammer does have ammo where's the last one it's over here wall breach incoming i mean it does say six but like objective completed yeah it's the tfim moment okay this is a lot harder than tfim There's actual,
like, pullback tab.
I feel like, guys, I have a feeling this might be hard.
Oh, wait.
Our sound guy's actually here.
Okay, there we go.
Sound guy nothing.
There we go.
Sound team is actually here.
Look, I was told, look, sound guy, I was told by one of the other mods that you were not going to wake up.
It was not, I mean, I was just told the information that I was given.
So, but yeah, sound guy.
Just feel free to tell me about the sound in our screen.
That's what you meant, Annabelle.
Tamir, I'm not going to lie, I was thinking about sleeping in.
Look, I'm just a message.
Don't shoot the messenger.
I'm literally just told what I was given.
Anyway, I was told to show a couple of videos.
I haven't seen these videos before, so I'm blind reacting with you guys.
So let me check out the videos real quick.
Well, they're not quick, but you know what I mean.
so yeah we're gonna be checking out the videos of pubg a blind spot and also um if you guys can feel free to do the survey linked in uh pinned in my chat or use the qr code it really does help out the stream a lot and you have a chance to win a 50 steam what is it called uh 50 steam code um and um again thank you again for pubg uh for sponsoring this stream uh make sure to right now on Steam.
Yippee.
All right.
Let me double check and everything.
All right, here we go.
Let's check out the video.
Oh my God, now.
Yes, you can, or you can go to San Diego TwitchCon right now to try out the game.
It won't be that, it can't be that hard to go to San Diego in the United States of America.
Yeah, right now.
Book your tickets.
Right now to go to San Diego TwitchCon to try out PUBG blind spot in person Be right back gonna be on a 16 hour flight Yeah, give me like two minutes.
I'll be there.
Don't worry All right, let me Grab the video.
I think this is the right video.
I hope it is yeah all right this is like a character trailer whoa also drop out oh yeah this is the character we look at her she's four to five i'll make sure it doesn't loop though oh yeah that's the green that's the toxic gas i was talking about i tried to use that in a 1v2 scenario it um did not work out for me because also like oh what was funny was that oh she's cute what was funny was that i didn't realize you know search and destroy there's two points so i like i like fenced up point a and i was like i got this and then they're like they're like um diffusal like the the encryption key has been planted and i was like where i didn't look i was like there's a b spy so i was like obviously as a solo person in a one v2 um it was not ideal for me did she did it I absolutely did not know
yeah so I definitely did not know not my spot not my the problem is is that both spots were my spots but no the character ability seemed really cool I can't wait to try out all the other abilities like i said are all the other like weapons that the characters have um because i said there's a lot lots of characters and a lot of different utils and stuff all right here's the next one this is one where we all go uh of a live streamer oh it's a live streamer tournament and then five and okay so these are like actual good players playing this game not like me not like me i don't know what i'm doing for us btk you're holding yeah so there's the yeah this is like what we are i um wish we could do side flank but btk master is waiting for it he keeps looking over in that direction but hadn't spotted him yeah because i have to oh my gosh i gotta be like um i'm so bad with you too i'm sorry moxie good luck so i'm so i feel like we're gonna get like dunked on I'm so bad with you,
Tilt.
I don't know.
I feel like I feel like I'm going to get dunked on.
Good luck, Moxie.
I'll be watching you.
No, you Tilt.
You think I could just, like, run up?
Oh, we have a guy to sneak up to someone.
Because, like, you know, it's third person.
They can't see from behind.
So if I can sneak up to someone from behind.
Got one.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Like, they see one tiny thing.
What's in the MIP?
Yeah, that blue thing damages people I believe in Moxie I believe in Moxie, he's a gamer Oh my god, this guy Okay, that's okay You did not need to sacrifice your life to plant that bomb I'll be in the blind spot That's right
No, I'll do the charge up behind them before they they can see me oh and then they have to crouch and everything that was a good first message roll the credit i still don't know what camera angle to use best thank you again the pubg blind spot for the sponsor i really appreciate it uh uh all right so sound team said there's no adjustments yet okay good we're gonna you're gonna have to start we're good luck with adjusting when we're in the voice call though good luck it's that's always the hard part when you have to do the vc adjustments um okay let me double check okay they're like technically in the vc but like we're not supposed to do anything yet so i don't have to go in um I don't know,
I'm like, there's a shooting range.
I don't know, like, what character, okay, who?
Shotgun.
Has to be a shotgun.
Uh, the motion detector.
Oh my god, explosive hammer.
Oh my god.
Wait, I know what character to use.
This is it.
Boom, there you go.
I don't know.
We smashed.
This is the smash.
Okay, but I do have a...
shotgun see boom that's what i mean this guy this gun can like one shot like it was not fun i think like if you aim at the head maybe yeah if i was close enough it's hammer oh wait no audio oops give me a sec i gotta fix that it's because i muted it because we're watching that video but yeah i think if i aim the head maybe i can get like a one shot maybe I'll just be like,
I'll be like this.
And like, pop, pop.
Uh, here's the, here's the breach.
What is this, though?
And then grenade.
I'm so bad with using details.
I don't know how to grenade.
I like other people grenade for me.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
This is a really, really nasty spread.
oh my god the the spread for this is a little weird okay yeah the spread for this can you all bounce i think i can let me check frag out yeah you can okay but the bounce isn't that it's not that much but you can it's it's it is bouncing it is bouncing it's just not like a big bounce but it does you know it i mean okay so but you can't do like a hide girl like that you can't do that and then i almost died but you know that is a possibility uh okay but how close can a grenade be to me before i die okay wait but like can i kill myself with this actually wait i don't know if it's like me i don't know if that's like me uh being in the training ground so like i always live with one hp yeah i just always live with one hp okay it's all right what about here okay so i have to be like here to not accidentally kill myself like
okay that's good to know i have to be here to make sure i don't you know kill myself with my grenades in game um apparently grenades hurt a lot it's crazy Isn't it?
Is that?
Fun fact!
If you stand next to a grenade, you might lose your legs.
Okay, more than just your legs.
A little fun fact.
You can hammer run plus grenades.
Oh my god, you're right!
Wait, I could be like...
You're right.
If I'm about to die, I chuck the grenade at my feet.
Oh my god, you're right.
Wait, I should do that.
If I knew I'm about to die, I'll just chuck the grenade at my feet.
and then I'll be like it's over I'm gonna have all these plans and then I won't even execute any of them I could feel it I I know I would have all these fun plans and then like I don't I don't even get anything um and we die we both die I'm gonna forget it frame one hundred percent uh
yeah oh I can slam here okay um i just want to use the shotgun characters okay so there's the motion sensor motion detector placed that place it okay i don't know the range for it i think like when you're on the enemy team you'll see the range for it but yeah oh yeah so like the first gun only does oh my there's okay there's so bm but where is it this guy so the goddamn one of um the fortnite there used this uh n pen and then like it was i killed it was a 1v1 because i killed uh i killed sunny and then um and then literally this guy just did this and he planted the bomb and i couldn't do anything about it he just he just i caught a person i
he actually and they're like because he already planted the bomb so like if i go diffuse he can do this and shoot me like he can just do this and shoot me if i if i like try and diffuse so i was i didn't have nades i used up all my nades that's the worst part i already used up all my nades when i was like breached like when i was trying to breach the goddamn point um so so i just stood i gave up i just stood there and just let the bomb kill me i i don't know you can have her i I feel like I'm gonna hammer the shield here,
doesn't I?
I don't know.
Maybe next time I see that, I'm gonna hammer the shield next time.
I I was just like, what do I do?
He's just standing there with a shield.
What do I do?
I feel like you could literally just watch.
Honestly, maybe that's the strat.
One guy, maybe I can, I...
Maybe that's the strat.
I go up, walk over there and just...
Okay, I gotta make sure, like, they don't have grenades.
But I could just walk up there and then Moxie can just shoot them all.
Because, like, I've tried nothing, I'm out of option.
Wait, can I shoot?
I don't think you can.
I don't know.
I should have shot the feet just to make sure.
But... No, he just... You know what you do when he walks behind me?
That's what I did!
I was like, okay, I'll just walk behind.
And then he just did this.
I don't think I could do.
I...
I tried.
I walked behind him!
He just did this!
He just...
Um...
So, I don't know.
Good luck, Voxy.
I believe in you.
Your greatest weakness of shield.
I mean, there is this guy.
What is this?
You two.
what did i do i'm going i'm hacking into the system uh oh wait does it say oh it doesn't say oh here it is uh court after each use oh increases the movement speed now do i put it in do i just walk around with this i'll be like don't worry guys i got you i just i just want don't worry maxi i got you i sat in a corner and i just like Charging.
I just stand here in the corner and feel like Charging.
Oh, and there.
I'm the hype man.
Can I, like, reset it?
Okay, so, like, basically I do this.
And do I still...
Oh, I get...
Oh, okay, I don't have to hold it out.
That's good to know.
So, like, I basically...
Oh, my God.
It's so slow, though.
Oh, my God!
Bus someone!
That is so smart.
we can buff it and then run in with a hammer wait i don't get a hammer here wait who i have to play this guy if i want to use the hammer all right so so moxie can use this i'll do this i'll be like buff me up and then i run in the the most important two seconds of my life i hammer time the hammer um i tried this person because i thought like oh i'm by myself let me just launch a grenade into it little did i know it's one bullet so my plan failed instantly um so so i was like i was like all right it's one v two i got this when they go plant the bomb i i use the grenade launcher into the play and then like um i tested it i was like testing it out like they we you know it was defense so i was testing it out and then it was and then like it was i realized wait where's it's one bullet because i was like i'm ready they breached it and then they're in the point i was like i'm ready and i was like i was like wait a minute where are the bullet wait a minute one bullet and no dream so that was a
little oopsie that i did where i i i accidentally how bad is the flash okay it's not okay i know it's pretty bad it's pretty bad uh that's not supposed to happen i think it's more like the equipment and stuff that you see in uh uh pubg um but thank you again pubg for the sponsor feel free to do oh yeah feel free to do the survey scan the qr code or click on the link pinned in my chat i believe you can do the survey right now to what you feel about this game what's the drill oh i guess drill camera it's like you reach you start breaching oh wait that's cool oh wait it's two bullets oh that's cool this is like intel i could like if i'm breaching i could just why does this have three and my grenade launcher have like this is three and my grenade Lancer is one bullet.
Life's unfair, guys.
Smoke out.
Oh, here's the smoke.
Life's unfair.
Alright.
Smoke would be very important.
Life actually is unfair.
There's so many characters he is.
Oh my god, that recoil is insane.
You can only do, like, one bullet, I feel like, before things get messy.
You can't, you can't, like, continuously aim.
You actually have to, like, wait.
Wait, can I scan through smoke?
try well i don't know if i can try it for like my own team myself but um we'll see if it works and then i don't know okay go cam up oops i'm scanning the wrong side where's my drill camera guys the drill camera didn't didn't work okay i feel like maybe you can But I can't do it because I'm by myself Um
Okay here's the foam Foam grenades Look I can build my own wall I can build one wall
It's alright That one wall will clutch it Alright And then I can break my own wall I assume that breaks yeah that breaks it Uh my wall My one wall Okay The pistol odds can do headshots from what I've seen.
It's just the normal gun that does, like, regular...
Regular shots.
It's just a rig.
Just that...
Just body shots is a main gun.
And then the pistol is the...
You can change from headshot to body shot.
You can also do...
Feet shots, too.
But I don't know when...
When do I need to shoot the feet?
Like...
I don't know.
When will I ever need to shoot?
I guess like, oh, oh, oh, I forgot when you, when, you know, you breach the wall here and then you shoot the feet from that guy.
I realize, yeah, um, during shield.
All right, I'm going to test it.
I'm going to walk out with a shield and then we'll see if I die.
If they, if they know how to shoot the feet.
Let's see.
Well, we'll test that theory.
out if I die then I know they can shoot the feet what's this uh explosive oh yeah explosive trap yeah does he was he the one yeah so this guy just has a shotgun as a main weapon so that's not fun at all but obviously this is for defense he seems so you just put that that also messed me up like literally just walk through and then oh yeah I guess like yeah you got the trap ready yeah so and then boom you die i guess but then you also get a shotgun which is life is unfair like you can use oh my god wait this guy is op wait this guy's op for uh for defense i can hit my main weapon has the headshot wait what's my grenade for this smoke out okay maybe i'll try collision i don't have to aim i just have to be like i i don't have to aim technically Okay,
this one.
Okay, this one I was like I'm going to heal myself.
And then like, it was just too much.
Too much prep time.
Like, I know it's like two seconds, but like, I was getting chased at.
Like, there was no prep time for me.
Oh my gosh.
Do I have anything that does damage?
No, the shotgun was so strong.
I tried to play air because I was like, oh, I can heal myself, you know?
Like, thinking that I can just heal myself.
And then I was getting chased at by two people and then i was just like oh guess i no guess i don't no you have to let you walk when you start healing see that's that's way too much time like that's way too much time to grab a heal apparently in 15 minutes we're gonna do our 2v2 yeah um what else our last girl oh this one this one was she seems fun only because like um the thing is you can't really you can do this and and just like but also i messed up because i think it's also one bullet or two it depends on if you can grab ammo in time um but it doesn't last too long um um but it seemed really good for like you know they're at the point and you just like throw the gas out um you throw the gas out and then like hope everything will be okay you hope that they'll be there that's that's my hope uh yeah those are all the characters like i said there's so many different utils um so i don't know which one to use i don't know which would be the best one to use because there's just um it's
just so much util to to choose from um but yes please feel free to use the qr code um that's all displayed on the screen and um feel free to scan that or click on the link pinned in the chat again thank you again the PUBG for the sponsor.
Yay!
It's been fun checking this game out.
And say hello to the people at TwitchCon who are watching us right now.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I'll be the DEF CAM player.
Hello, everyone.
We'll mostly be at the DEF CAM, but that's okay.
I believe in Moxie.
I don't know.
I'm not like tactical shooters I'm sometimes I'm like not as confident only because like you have to be so patient and oh my god wait I don't know if moxie is patient but like I know I'm not patient you have to you're supposed to like you know sit down you know like sit here and wait but I'm like why wait when I can just run into the action but like but like that's not how you play tactical shooters so I need to like I need to sit here with my shotgun now and be like pop
I like the yeah I just want to run into the bullet I can't help it I'm gonna try collision okay I'm gonna try oh it's because like when you're crouched they move slow but um here they move pretty fast I'm very self-aware of like what my uh what my uh what my strong points are I'm I'm not I'm gonna use manual camera for now if I don't feel if it if you know if it doesn't work I'll swap to like the aiming one but for now try the manual um what's the line camera oh oh oh you can like auto align the camera I don't know when you'll have to do that god I'm so nervous not the drive by pop pop I guess I'll just be in this corner in my little corner i assume like we have our own vcs wait actually what if we're doing 2v2 are you going to be like carrying the other team because i see one vc i see i just see one vc so i'm a little confused about that um let me ask will there be a separate vcs
2v2 there you go yeah because I was like that's awkward if I could like hear they're like okay we're gonna do this and this and then I'm on the other team being like okay
I'll be like alright I guess they're gonna do this guys they're Or, um, yeah, one VC chaos.
I mean, I'd rather just do, like, these, like, separate VCs.
Or two V2, because I feel like that's a little bit too much.
All right.
There is in-game VC.
Um, where is it?
Yeah, push to talk.
I don't even know what my push to talk is.
I never had to for this game.
Oh, there you go.
Kio.
Hello.
Oh, yes, it, nope.
We'll never know.
all right here's the plan we're gonna try wilson and then moxie can aim i'll do this i'll be like i got you moxie and then he gets shot in the side but like it's the thought that counts you know like i i have a feeling um he's just gonna get shot in the side but it's the I did my best I know I did my best that's all that matters um that's all that matters oh yeah the shield has life it does but takes for ever it takes forever um wait I mean separate voice chats or are we going are are we going to hear the other team's comps during the 2v2
there was a miscommunication alright I'll be here for the tank gameplay right here oh okay they made a new voice chat
okay there you go okay there you go alright alright apparently I have to make the room I'll make the room right now all right custom game create game winners house uh this is a team death match all right copy all right got it i got the code there we go yeah i was gonna say it's awkward if we're all gonna share the uh we're all gonna share it and then like i'll be like hey guys hi i can oh we know their plan and now just type in chat what we do like i know because it's a tactical you know we gotta be tactical so i was just like god how do we need to out join the general all right i'm just gonna get the discord stuff going bum bum bum i'm just getting a discord stuff going right now wait can't connect i was gonna say how what do you mean you can't connect um what is this discord server called pubg blind spot all right i'm just getting the pubg thing set up uh and thank you again for the sponsor pubg i really appreciate it all right pubg blind spot there you go to be fair like wait where
is the the other section they create a new voice chat the overlay has yet to recognize it so that's a little awkward
because i'm like oh all right there you go wait why is there why is it tech oh oh it's because they create a text channel oh that's funny that they're like but i was like wait wait a minute where's a voice channel.
It was a, it was a text channel.
We're getting there.
Again, I'm excited.
I'm nervous.
Uh, one team, both teams has to type their comms.
We're in the, we're in the group, what you see?
And then we're just typing our comms like, we type our comms in the text channel.
We're like, we got this.
Yeah, we got this.
Okay.
That's funny.
Push A You know what would be cool Maybe in the future they can implement Oh I love it when you have the map Drawing a mechanic in Tactical shooters You stop mid-fight and like Like move to the Discussion and be like quick we gotta Rotate I want to I hope they implement a map feature So like obviously I'll use it For good
I'll use it I'll use it for good Obviously on the With the map feature
Global chat push Hey team chat push Me Look I would use it for good I would You'd know I would So You know I got I'm sorry, Steph.
I just thought it was funny.
I thought it was really funny, Steph.
I'm sorry.
Look, chat, chat.
We all thought it was funny, right?
Shout out to the staff at the PUBG blind spot booth.
We all thought it was really funny.
All right.
Hello.
Hello, hello, hello.
I'm nervous.
I don't play a lot of tactical shooters, so it's all on you, Moxie.
It's...
I believe in you.
Alright.
Alright, let's see.
Alright, we got to fix the...
They added a new VC.
Setup?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I posted the...
Yeah, yeah, I posted the server code.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah, I made the custom lobby.
Very nice.
Did you try out all the characters?
I did.
I don't know who I'm going to play, to be honest.
Yeah, okay, so like, because you weren't at the rehearsal.
So, like, the shotgun does so much.
Like, it was literally one shot.
So I should pick up the shotgun.
Yeah, no, you should pick up the shot.
Because, like, when we were doing the rehearsal, because I had to 1V2, And literally like there was no counterplay because like when they're up, you know, because it's tactical shoot They're right up to your face and then they just go bop and you're dead.
I'm like, okay I had to play like a rat, all right, listen, okay, I was not aware I was like, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, it's not like I skipped out on it.
They're like, he can't make it.
What do you mean?
They said he can't make it.
Why do you mean you weren't aware?
Like, it might have been, hey, I don't know, some things got mixed up.
Oh, yeah, yeah, this is, I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, it's okay, we can do this.
We don't need, you don't need tech rehearsal.
You don't need to know.
Yeah.
And I played the tour.
I played everything.
I get the feel.
I watched the trailer too.
Like, I see how high-level play goes.
Yeah, exactly.
You saw those high-level plays, like, how they were, like, like working together as team.
Okay, so this is my plan.
There's like this guy with a giant wall that he holds like a giant shield.
I'm gonna put that shield out.
Yeah, I'm gonna put that shield and you just shoot everyone.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know if they know you can shoot the toes yet.
So we'll see.
Oh, yeah, they probably didn't play the tutorial.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
They probably don't know.
Like who would think about shooting the feet, you know?
You aim for the hit all the time.
So maybe, and the shield has a lot of HP.
out that's great yeah the thing is how do i shoot from behind you one thing okay they won't see they only see me oh i'll be bait i'll go out and you go behind them and then you shoot them in the head and behind so i will peek out a little inch away from you yeah where they're already spamming all their bullets exactly and they have to reload you know okay so i was going when they reload okay yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's yeah see that's i don't know when they reload so like we're gonna figure that out we'll we'll get it figured out yeah it's team death match we have like we have like so many deaths before like it gets it gets into a problem like yeah yep oh i'll post i actually like this idea i'm telling you these guys actually probably have nothing planned exactly they're just look see in the discord they have their microphones muted they're not even talking to each other They're like solo.
They must be so awkward.
Yeah, yeah.
We have a plan and everything.
Like they're like, oh, I don't really know what to do.
Should I ask him?
No, make me think.
Yeah, I know.
Maybe we'll just shoot the gun, you know, just pick a character and shit.
But we're coming in with a strat.
We're going to farm them.
And we're going to get like zero deaths too.
Literally, literally.
Literally have a shield until they break the shield.
But that's not going to happen.
There's no way.
They're going to die.
before them yeah exactly they'll die before the shield is broken wait and i'll just throw a nade over you oh my god that's so true you can just throw a dade oh we'll just you just throw a dade he doesn't have a nade though he doesn't have an aid he has okay if he throws a nade we just we i just back away i walk backwards just and then my shield tanks the nade nice nice nice i was thinking i was gonna throw an aid but i don't i don't have one no we all have what do you mean we all have Okay,
well, my special ability.
Yeah.
Is, is a, is a, uh, like a trap.
Oh, you're going to use a traps and team deathmatch?
Where are we trapping?
I saw there was some good grenades.
I saw there was a lot of good grenades.
I'm not going to lie.
Okay, make sure you don't grab the character with a flash grenade or a smoke grenade.
So, because some characters only have flash or smoke.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I've seen that.
Okay, the flash was pretty OP though.
Like, you're literally blind.
Like, you only see, like, the tiny circle around you.
Oh, we're ready.
Okay.
So you do get blind once you get hit by a flash.
Yeah, it's not great.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
You get blind when you get hit by a flash.
Who would have thought?
Are you ready?
Yep, I'm ready.
All right.
We're going to have this whole plan and then we're going to get absolutely destroyed.
I feel like.
No, no, this is...
Like they have no plan.
Like we already know.
We already know.
All right, all right.
Okay, okay.
I got, okay.
I'm going in with...
But I don't know if you could change characters during death match.
So we got to commit to this.
Yeah, no, this has got to be the strat.
This is the word commitment.
Because if we lose, like, we have no other strat behind.
Yeah, this is our only strat.
Collision.
Okay, where are you?
Oh, there you go.
There you go.
Oh, you got this.
You got this.
There you go.
I hold this shield.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You can?
Don't shoot my head.
I don't see them.
Okay.
I thought I heard them.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I'm actually so scared.
I'm so scared too.
I'm so paranoid.
All right.
Don't worry.
I got your back.
Do I look backwards like this?
No, I die.
You're dead too.
Yeah.
I don't think I'm tired of the shield myself.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, I got your friend.
To our right.
No.
Oh, there you go.
Throw a grenade.
Yeah, throw it at me.
There's a smoke.
I told you, Boxy, to make sure it's a grenade.
I don't have a grenade.
It's a smoke.
I told you
Okay, okay, they did it stuff again.
They did it stuff.
We push up we push forward nice we push forward Oh, he's on the way.
I'm dead.
He's stuck behind the check.
What happened was he?
He's good.
Okay.
I'll be the shield maybe.
You be a shield.
All right.
Okay.
I got this.
All right.
He said press B.
Yeah.
B.
Oh, no.
No.
It doesn't work.
Oh, no.
It doesn't.
It doesn't work.
Oh, no.
It doesn't.
Oh, wait.
The right.
There, there, there.
Okay.
Oh, wait, wait.
I was like, I was like, you bait, you bait.
Oh my god, they phone walled.
They're actually there.
I'm so scared.
I'm here.
What's going on?
I thought you had a plan.
You could have swung here.
No, no, I had no plan.
Oh my god, I'm getting old.
I got her.
Nice.
Okay.
Okay, maybe you should shoot.
I'm bad at this.
Wait, one, one.
She's one.
all right what he's gonna have no idea i'm gonna hide oh my god oh my god yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good that's good okay you you tell them where they are i'll flank i'll start flanking i have no idea where they are okay when you figure it out when you figure it out i'll start flanking they'll never know okay they sound like they're near me they'll never know are they actually near you Yep,
yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Okay, don't die!
Don't die!
Oh my god, I can't, I can't, I can't look back both ways.
It's okay.
It's okay, they won't know.
They're in the, they're in the grass, they're in the grass.
Where's the grass?
What's the grass?
Right there, right there, right there, in between us.
Oh no, in front of us.
Okay.
Oh my god, guys, shotgun, shotgun is close range.
Who would have thought?
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna go flank.
Oh, he's just lit.
Oh no.
Okay, I saw I get okay.
Okay, I have it.
I have it.
I can swap.
Okay.
Because they're using shields.
They're cheating.
Okay.
I think our plan we should have kept with the shield plan.
I'm pretty sure we should.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here with the shield.
All right.
We got this.
We just got key with the shield.
They're on the right.
All right.
I'm behind.
Oh.
Wait, can you shoot through that?
I don't think you can.
Yeah, maybe.
Yeah.
Probably on the outside.
Oh, right there in front.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
I have a need.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna go behind you.
You go shield that, but you won't know.
Okay, okay.
Yep.
You're gonna have to get him.
Oh my god.
I had to reload.
You got this.
Shoot him.
I'm pulling off my gun.
You're pulling off the gun.
I killed him.
Yes, I told you I got it.
Okay.
You go get he'll help back.
There's a help back right here.
There's a else back right here Come.
No, wait, no, no.
He's over here.
Oh my god, I got him.
Oh my god.
You own them.
Yeah, I own them.
I own them.
I'm a pro player now There's also I hear footsteps Bender.
Oh my god, his one.
Yes!
We got him!
Get the help back again.
30 seconds.
Oh my god.
Wait, we can catch up.
We can totally catch up.
This bad.
This is bad.
We got this.
Okay, to be fair, we didn't know.
No!
That's fine.
We were learning.
We were learning, you know, we were figuring it out and then it took us a while to get the shield going.
Okay, well I'm just saying the shield.
Okay.
She's right.
She can flank him.
Flank him.
Yes.
Look at that.
We should have done that.
No, no, no.
Yeah, we should.
Honestly, I'm starting to think like, maybe I'm not that good with a shotgun.
This is the only time I've gotten the kill.
only gotten kills with his gun so this is bad this is bad okay but we figured it out though we've downloaded the system we we figured it out oh no okay okay it's just one guy we just got killed that guy and then it's fine because look at he got all the kills look at this dad see this it's literally him okay and pen must be a gamer then yeah no he's a pro player so like Oh,
okay.
We just need to kill him and then we win.
Okay, okay.
That's okay.
We're fine then.
We're fine.
It's just it's just him.
Think of a way to kill him.
I think we do the shield thing.
We do the shield thing.
But like you it's like that bait thing, you know, like we bait them and then.
Oh, by the way, friendly fire is on.
Oh, okay.
Do we?
Because I was thinking I might have shot you.
I was like, whoa, you're doing damage.
All right.
Do we do we do team death match again?
or do we do search and destroy because like i didn't think it would go that fast all right yeah i'm gonna do i'm gonna do death match again all right let's do that again i feel like we can oh yeah 10 minutes okay all right yeah that's another he doesn't need to be ready that's okay all right this is fine this is fine our strat okay so you shield you bs bait i flank or either one of us baits the other guy we figured it out I have him.
But honestly, I kind of like this guy's gun.
Oh, yeah, like the...
What gun do you have?
This shield guy's gun.
You just see, like, an MP9?
Oh, shit.
I think mine's an AK.
I mean, it looks like an AK.
Okay.
All right.
You go in.
I'll go flag.
You go in and distract them.
I feel like I know where they're going to go.
They always go in the center.
Yeah, no.
I think they're going to go where we first met them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You go in the courtyard.
I'll slowly head.
Yep, yep, yep, you've seen them.
They're deep.
They're deep as far ahead where we first met them.
Okay Oh, they're they're in front of me now.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
You can live right you can survive Yep, okay.
Wait, he's peeking.
I get I can't ping him or anything.
Oh, there's he's pulling out a gun The other guy has a gun the other guy has a gun.
Okay.
I'm reloading.
You got this live All right.
I'm flanking.
I'm flanking you just live Oh my god the reload the way it's actually it's actually really you got this right they're getting angles You're getting angles.
I'm going to I'm flanking right now.
I'm flanking right now.
Okay.
I hit one.
I hit one I got it.
I got it.
She's on me.
No, he got me Hold on.
I'm looking.
Oh Nice.
Nice.
He's one.
He's so low.
I'm coming over.
Oh my god.
I'm getting shot from behind Oh, no!
Oh, wait, you!
You almost got it.
You almost got it, though.
It was so close.
I'm here.
I'm here as well.
She's one.
Nice.
Oh, he's thinking.
He's so low.
I have to reload.
Nice.
As I see, look at that.
We're figuring it out.
We figured it out.
Can we- we were playing too scared?
Like, we're way better.
Yeah, we're so much better.
We're gamers.
I told you, we get rid of everything.
It's easy.
Same spot.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
He went back to the shield.
Oh, my God.
He's shielding?
He's always, oh, he got him.
Nice.
Yes, I got him, I got him.
That's what we do.
We flanked.
Yeah, where's that spawn?
I don't know.
It's back there.
You see that red...
Red area?
Yeah, it's right there.
Now we're in there, spawn.
Now we're spawned in there.
I'm gonna...
Okay, okay I'm gonna use a hammer.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm trying to hammer the beast!
You got this!
Oh, no, oh, no, oh, no, oh, oh, no!
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, no, you will put me in a bad spot!
Okay.
as well as I thought it would.
Yeah, I feel like a hammer doesn't really beat a gun most times.
Yeah, for some reason, the hammer is not as strong as I thought it would be.
Who would have thought?
I got two.
How did they get five?
I don't even remember dying five times.
Yeah, because I died three times.
Oh, yeah.
I'm going left.
Let me know if you see that.
Oh, they're right in front of me.
They're in front of me.
Okay, I'm flanking.
I'm flanking.
They don't know.
Oh, oh man, I'm hit.
I'm hit.
Okay.
Oh my god, what?
He headshot me.
Holy shit.
Okay.
I was not expecting that headshot.
Okay, I gotta use my terrain better.
I gotta crouch underneath terrain.
Yeah, yeah, we gotta.
He like shot me in the head, I think.
I'm gonna crouch.
He can't shoot me in the head if I'm crouched.
Can't headshot me.
Yep.
I actually think they won't keep that in mind.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no way they'll know.
I'm gonna do the longest flank of my life, so live.
Oh, he's one in front of me.
He's hiding.
I don't see him.
I got him.
There we go.
See, this is the strike.
Oh, we get the help back.
There's a help back in front of you.
I'm glad you're like an ammo box.
Oh, wait.
That is.
No, no, it is a help back.
Oh, no, no.
To your left, to left.
Back left.
Yeah, hide out.
Couch, crouch, crouch.
I'm crouching.
Oh, my God.
He almost got me.
Nice.
Oh, he's pushing me.
Wait, wait.
No, no, no, she's not.
She's not.
Oh, no, no.
You shoot this, no.
Okay, I'm pushing.
You're cooked.
Oh, you're cooked!
You're cooked!
Oh, shit!
I'm one!
Oh, I'm coming back with a grenade!
No, I couldn't!
That's 1 HP!
You got me!
Oh, they can catch up.
I realize we have... We do have names.
I'm gonna use my name.
Oh, I hit him.
Grenade.
That's my name!
Okay, I'm doing a... Nice?
I hit him a little bit.
Okay, I'm reloading.
Oh, you can... You can wallbang, by the way.
All right, they're- Oh, they're all looking at me!
They're looking at me!
Oh, no.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
To the right.
They're like...
Over here.
My right?
The right ping.
I think they ran off.
We got this.
Moxie, careful.
They could...
You'll get caught to the left, too.
Okay, okay.
We...
I mean, Loki, we got 15 seconds.
Loki, by the night.
Just run.
Oh, no, no, no!
I'm stuck!
Oh no, it's fine.
Oh no, we gotta get killed.
We gotta get killed.
We gotta kill him.
We gotta kill him better.
Oh no, oh no.
Wait, this is deathmatch.
It's a draw.
no we had it we had it why did we rush why did we do that i don't know we're just look we're just blood thirsty okay we don't we have to be patient we're just alpha yeah we're just yeah yeah yeah we're just alphaing it okay yeah that's that's it that's it we're not pussies we're not pussies yeah we're not stupid yeah we're just alpha what do you mean i threw moxie died first And then I threw after him.
It's a team game, you know?
It's a team effort.
Yeah, it's a team effort.
We wanted to be, we wanted to throw together.
We actually want them to think we're, you know, we're bad.
Because like, yeah, and then the third game is where we turn it around.
This is where we turn it around.
Yeah, right here.
We got this.
We have the strat now.
Oh, they were like jump over.
Okay, I accidentally started.
this fast it's okay we can make this fast i'm ditching the shield i'm gonna give the shotgun one more try and give the shotgun one more try i believe okay but they're so far they've been doing range though to me yeah yeah they even wait maybe if i do desert eagle and oh wait i have a plan i have a plan i'm using what's your plan what's your plan i have a desert eagle i just headshot okay oh okay that's okay that's good that's a good plan And then I have this.
Watch.
This is a camera.
Look, see?
It gives us intel.
Oh, they left the match.
Okay, never mind.
They left the match.
Yeah, we gotta do a team game.
We gotta leave.
I guess we have to leave.
It's okay.
I'd run away too.
Yeah, exactly.
They're running away.
They're so scared of us.
They knew we were evolving.
Yeah, they knew each game.
We, they knew.
They knew.
they were like they were so scared because we figured out the strat so they're like we don't want to play against them anymore we won by default it's technically one one exactly yep yeah yeah because we didn't quit we ain't no quitters yeah yeah no they they they forfeited yeah they forfeited exactly we take that all right i put the new server yeah yeah it's in the general
here okay okay i'm joining oh i'm starving what did you eat today what i actually haven't had anything because it started like 9 30 9 30 a.m for me okay okay yeah because i'm in west coast all right okay this is search and destroy so you know like how with the plant or like breach was so we're attacking right now so okay um i don't know what to play I don't Yeah,
I'm not sure I'm not sure I'm gonna have to bring you a hammer guy out I mean, I could start hammering Yeah, I might I might pull him out I don't know Oh, you're gonna do the hammer guy Well, I'm gonna look at the map first And then decide Okay I don't know Okay,
so There's two points for this map Alright Only the defense Let's see Oh like 12 seconds to figure out what we want to play i feel like because this is close quarters i feel like i should be playing shotgun you want to do a hammer gun now uh if i can find them no no no it's next to me it's next to me okay oh no okay i have a shotgun though so it should be fine i'm down to start at the park where are we oh there is the park okay well that's so far though shouldn't we be at the staircase it's closer to the point what i was thinking i was like i was like okay the staircase is like one entryway oh also i wanted to see the park because i wanted to see the the the the scenic route oh that's true i just want to see how outside look and then like they have to wait for us so they'll be like so paranoid while we're like slowly walking over yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they'll be way too paranoid well i love how they did this outside all right Where's the map?
Oh, there it is.
We got a breach anyway.
Alright.
Oh, breached.
It breached.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is actually like...
This is actually... I feel like they'd be like on the point and stuff.
They definitely have set up traps and everything.
I'll be right behind you.
Devices.
Oh, it's a motion.
You got motion detected.
They know!
I'm spotted.
They spotted you.
I'm going to the other way i hear one on my left oh oh oh they're gonna flank you by gentlemen by gentlemen yep two of them i hear him nice yeah let's go oh my god why did they push up on their defense yeah they gotta they gotta hold the point yeah i guess because you think okay yeah rookie mistake look at that rookie mistakes rookie okay so it's carnivores all the way far right is this guy what now i'm thinking like i'm thinking i just i just 2v1 like i look oh 2v1 that's true you might as well just stay you know what yeah i'll be hammered this guy yeah yeah but at the same time do we really need to hammer anything i just fisted that door two times and it was done that's so true i feel like hammer is just like a state what if i hammer them from behind you think oh wait hold on you get a hammer kill they're actually ruined yeah yeah yeah it'll be ruined then it'll be like so easy okay so like you actually think starting at the park did help That's true.
No one came, like what's good.
Yeah, yeah, it made them so paranoid.
And they pushed out us.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
They didn't stay in their point, they're like, oh, maybe they're still trying to figure out where to go.
They're so lost, which we were, but we used that to our advantage.
Yeah, exactly.
It was planned.
Yeah, it was so planned.
Like, you could break down if you want.
Or we're going here or which way?
Oh, yeah, we'll go this way.
All right, I'm just being silly.
I have a shotgun.
All right.
Maybe we purposely find our detectors.
Wait, are you motioned?
No, no, no, no, no.
I accidentally pinged.
I was looking at the map.
Okay.
I'll go to the right.
If I get shotgun, that is my bad.
Okay, I'm at the same spot I was at before.
And I'm at that other spot I was at before.
Okay, I'm literally so far away from you.
This is...
Oh, this is bad.
I'm making my way back.
That is bad.
We gotta stick together.
Motion.
Okay.
I shot it.
I shot the motion.
Oh, you should have.
Oh, you should have used that motion to your advantage.
Oh, should I?
Yeah, yeah.
Like bait them out, you know?
Oh, what's that?
They made a foam wall.
Oh, my God.
They're playing on site.
They're so smart.
When we go to A.
I think we should go A.
We should go A.
Yeah, we should go A then.
Yeah, I see.
I see her.
Wait.
I'm gonna go.
We have one minute.
I'm gonna do the long ass thing.
Did you need yourself?
Yeah, kind of.
I feel like we could go A.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, okay.
Should I come with you?
Wait, wait, actually, we can breach that wall.
You see that wall?
Let's breach it.
Yep, yep.
I got the hammer.
You ready?
Okay, okay.
You cover me.
I'm breaching.
Oh, I messed up.
Breach, for real!
Don't chase, chase, chase!
Oh, he's close, he's close, I got him!
Oh, my God!
Next, he's one, he's one.
Help, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Look, look, look.
We did.
Oh, my God.
I don't.
No, no, no, the hammer's broken.
They're like, yeah, no, no.
They're not going to run the hammer.
Okay, I might have missed, but it still worked.
The plan still worked.
They're like, what was that thump?
Yeah, what was that?
Who came?
Who did that?
Yeah, there's no way they're running the hammer.
No way.
Who would hammer the wall?
Who's that stupid?
Little did they know.
They're that stupid.
Oh, we're defending.
Oh, I blinked.
We're defending.
Okay, well.
Okay, so I have a hammer for defense.
Setting wire.
I'm putting fences.
I'm gonna put fences on this wall.
Setting wire.
Wait, did you guys defend the point A?
Wait, I'm point A?
Your point B?
Yeah.
I started at point B.
What do you mean?
I thought it was like a, I thought it was like a, like let him, you know, flip a...
Oh, that's true.
We could flip it.
That's true.
Should we do that?
I'm just putting barbed wire anywhere.
Hold on.
Wait, wait.
I'll play.
Oh, wait.
I got a plan.
Setting wire.
I'll play here.
If I die, I die.
Okay, I got two of my barbed wires up.
Oh my God.
Wait, I hear it.
Wait.
Was that you?
was not me they're on me oh my god we're gaming we figured it out their their morale is the mollusk they're like wait this is so easy we we won versus them tied it's because like you know like team death match was a worry about this is the real game this is the real this is the real gives where we use our brains and our iq is bigger than theirs yeah no 100 yeah 100 yeah oh my god you're 22.4 accuracy your gaming is that oh whoa whoa look at that all right okay yeah i knew that i knew i was in shots yeah you knew you knew what was going on yeah when they're close to me like that with a shotgun it's i feel like that 22 is not that good with a shotgun like that close dude he was fisting me with the shield he didn't know what to do they tried to use a shield strat in that search and destroy yeah these guys need to lock in they need to lock in are you ready we're doing hospital now okay okay all right we're attacking again okay i got my hammer
it's a lot smaller yeah it looks a lot smaller oh my god there's this guy he's breaching that wall on the right now i see that yeah he's using our yeah that's yeah he's using our we we made the strat this is our meta i can't believe they implemented to the game so fast i know okay let me i'm running the shotgun this this kayak guy yeah change stun don't change what ain't broke something like that all right we got this all right defense or offense we're offense all right where do we want to go okay we could do the outskirts and or part like do the main entrance and just slowly walk there i've yeah i feel like they literally like they're like yeah they won't go through the entrance yeah yeah yeah they're like so paranoid too yeah and they're definitely not going to be holding sight like they're bro they're gonna be you know they're gonna be uh un impatient that's so true i mean they walked out like twice they did that we figured it out they're not patient i mean we walked out too shoot
some gunfire like oh that's true that's true we be like and they're like who are they fighting oh yeah they're so confused they're so confused yeah they're like fighting we're fighting our inner demons.
Like, they don't know.
It's actually PvE.
There's PvE.
Zombies come out?
Yeah, the zombies are coming out.
We're PvEing right now.
So they'll get curious.
Where is that point?
Oh, wait.
Did you hear that?
Oh, oh, yeah.
No, I hear some...
There is a character that shoots motion, like...
Motion sensors, yeah.
Through the walls.
Okay, it's to our left.
The site?
Is it?
No, it's very dead.
What is it not?
It's A and B.
Oh, I'm looking at the wrong...
Sorry, my camera angle is looking at the wrong...
My camera angle is not the right way.
Oh, they have the foam wall.
You see that?
I see that.
We have wires here.
They have wires.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's time to breach soon.
I...
You have foam walls.
Oh, I feel like this is a free breach.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel like they foam themselves off.
by the way cover me cover me yep yep yep yep yep yep yep yep oh we're in there we're so in there i'm going to oh my god i got i got one but i'm so i'm so messed up i think i have brain damage
I didn't know how to play it.
30 seconds remaining.
Oh my god.
Bro, he's just using the wall!
Oh wait.
I can crouch.
No!
He was so sneaky!
He's so sneaky!
Oh my.
He's so sneaky.
Okay.
Wow.
You know what?
They played that whole pretty good.
They played that.
They defended that pretty good this time.
They're evolving.
I feel like there's normally not a hole there, but they made one.
Yeah, they made the hole to make sure that we would...
Oh my gosh, I should have faked it and go to the other side.
But then I was scared of the wires.
Alright, they won't expect us to be super close to them, right?
Surely.
Because, like, we've always been playing so far.
Do you want to go through emergency room?
Oh, yeah, we should.
We should.
I feel like I feel like they're setting up thinking we're going this way yeah yeah we how are you paying that x x oh yeah we should go here and then we go from oh we breach here we breach here oh my god wait look at use the waypoints with that oh my god there's some good damn arrows okay all right where the heck is oh I already I'm already confused where we are yeah like where are wait oh it's still it's here it's here it's here this is the emergency i'm moving do we break this i mean there's an edge at regular it wait what do you see that oh my god wait yeah that was our reflection oh is that reflection oh i was like oh i hate you i'm sorry i'm sorry oh no oh my god oh my god you're actually so low oh my god it's over that is it's over before i'm gonna hit you two times in the back of that oh my god i was like i was like this is not breaking concussion Okay,
remember there was a wall we could breach?
Yeah, there's a wall here, but I'm just crouching under it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I wonder if they can see us.
Oh, sneaky.
I can breach that wall.
You think it's worth it?
Can they hear us if we're doing this?
I think they don't can't hear the crouch.
Are you ready?
I'm gonna breach it.
Oh, I will get shot.
I will get shot the moment I do this.
So you better be ready.
Ready?
Okay, three.
Ready to breach the wall.
Nowhere.
Oh.
I don't see them.
Okay, I'm actually Loki really scared.
I'm so paranoid right now.
I'm so paranoid, Moxie.
Where are they?
I don't know.
Do I shoot this barbed wire?
Do you shoot it?
Nope.
Oh my god, they're right here.
They're right here.
You know when you like meleeed me twice?
Oh, that guy's one.
So like I'm not okay right now.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
I'll come over from the other side.
I went through the world I got it.
I got it.
I am one HP Moxie.
I've looked at my help bar.
I should not be alive.
You try to melee me.
I try.
Okay.
Oh, you got me.
I tried.
Okay.
I'm going to try.
I'm going to try dropout.
Okay.
She has like a gas.
Yeah, I'm going Hayes.
Alright.
Oh, I heard he has a Digo, so he might be able to get a headshot.
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna definitely hit those.
Yeah, I believe.
What's the worst that can happen?
I was going for the cameras.
I think the cameras go through walls, this guy.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, it does.
Okay, I'm gonna put the other one right here.
Oh, wow, it does.
they don't do they haven't fortified the walls so that's what i'm doing i i didn't even know you could do that it's it was in the tutorials well i was in my tutorial i i'll come over to you okay okay well i feel like we're we're stacking this one oh yeah yeah well we'll stack here we're all in all in in this one i have okay okay oh wait they're going is it to my right drill cam up wait maybe drill cam here
wait i have an idea i will shoot this gas if they come in here and they won't be able to see
no i think they're behind behind it'll be sad if they went a like i have no plan for a yep watch this yep they have a they have a shield should we just break this wall yeah i gas it i gas it you might go to a now Oh, wait, wait, you're right.
We should shoot A.
Okay, I'm up.
Let's shoot.
Let me break this.
So I shot my...
Oh, oh, oh, they're at the door.
They're at the door.
I see them.
Oh, they're breaching.
Oh, never, never...
You see them.
You see them, right?
Yeah, yeah, I see them.
I see them.
They were like on the other side.
Oh, they're actually so scared.
They're actually so scared.
Oh, my God.
You hide, Moxie hide.
One minute remaining.
Okay, okay.
I'm behind this.
They're gonna walk in.
They're gonna get sprayed down.
and the second they played at this bomb.
They're going, hey, they're breathing.
Come, come, come, come.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm sorry, I was hiding.
Oh my God.
Well, he's like, you wanna slowly walk on him?
Yeah, I'm coming over.
He's one, he's one, he's one, he's one.
Oh my God, I ran out of bullets.
Oh my God, okay, go, go, go, go, go, go.
We got it, yeah.
One more, one more.
Oh, we're in their heads, we're in their heads.
I'm telling you this dream this drill camera like they actually get so spooked out.
Yeah.
Yeah, so oh my god Wait, I have explosive traps.
I can put explosive traps too Okay, yeah, we should do we should do that.
Yeah, folded shield
We're we're in there.
We're reading their minds right now.
Yeah, they're like Oh, should we go back to the shield?
Like what the shield worked in team death match, but this is not team death match.
Yeah, this is not no team death match This is where you gotta use your brains.
Lock in.
We're so locked in.
Deploy barric- can I barricade the door?
Oh my god, I can't- Oh my god, wait, we can barricade the door!
Oh my god, why have we been doing that?
We should have been barricading the door!
We barricade that door.
What do we want to barricade?
This one?
Yeah.
Setting wire.
I'm gonna do what we played before.
And now I'm gonna put- I'm gonna put my explosives thing here.
Okay, okay, okay.
Traps set.
Oh god, be careful.
They're coming in soon.
Okay, I'm not running out of barricades.
Trapped ready.
I swear to God, they shot you while you're trying to put barricades on, I swear to God.
It's not stopping.
It's not stopping, he just keeps barricading.
Wait, if you're gonna barricade, I would barricade this.
What the fuck?
They'll never- And make a hole?
Make a hole in the wall we have?
Make a hole.
Wait, I should make a hole here.
Wait, wait.
Make a hole here.
They're not coming from my side.
There you go.
Wait, I'll come...
I'll make a tiny hole here.
So, like, we have, like, two ways.
Oh, they're...
They're...
They're, like, why are they...
It's all barricaded.
They're so confused.
Should I drill camera something?
Which is the word?
I feel like we should hear a sound before we drill camera.
I don't hear anything.
Yeah, what are they sneaking though?
Oh, that's true.
It's up to you.
Use your brain.
You're like 999 IQ.
I believe in you, Moxie.
I don't know.
I'm going to waste it.
They ain't breached.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, they breached it!
Oh!
What the thing?
Oh my god.
30 seconds remaining.
You saw him.
You saw him, right?
Yeah, I saw him.
Wait, so I don't have long range.
Oh wait, I do.
I have a pistol.
Oh, I'm hit.
Oh my god, I'm hit too.
No!
Oh no.
This is bad.
10 seconds remaining.
Wait, 6 seconds.
Oh my god.
Oh
That was so genius, but I actually I feel like it didn't I feel like they should have ran out of time But I think if you planted it doesn't stop unless that's messed up.
Oh my god I was like oh, so genius.
I know that's so much my plan.
It was my plan Oh, it's 2-2.
It was 0 for one entire second.
So I was waiting for it to count down.
I lost track of my character.
I forgot which character I was playing.
What are you playing?
I'm playing I'm playing Hayes, I think.
Okay, okay, I'm going.
Do we do emergency?
It worked.
It has always worked.
I like stopped shooting because I was like, oh, they couldn't plant it.
Yeah, no, you had that.
You had that.
Now we know.
now we know now we know i think it's because we put all our stuff on the other on point b so that why are we pushing this all right it's it's two two now oh i think it's over tab all right here we go all right okay it's tab oh yeah i hear them all right same strat yeah yeah yeah i would sneak you beaky like yeah they can't hear us
all right that guy felt real close oh oh saw that do it they didn't they threw something they threw something sound like a knade yeah oh it's the phone yeah yeah yeah all right i'm ready to breach that same area oh my god
I get close to the wall, I can scan through it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, you should do that.
Will they see you think?
I think they'll know.
Oh, wait, go over here.
Okay, I'm breaching it.
You ready?
Wait, I don't know.
What is that?
Yeah, I'm not too sure.
Okay, I'm preaching it regardless.
Ready?
Three, two, one.
Oh, it's fortified.
Oh, my God, it's fortified.
All right, I'm gonna do it again.
Three, two.
Okay, God cover me.
Ready to breach the wall.
Oh, they made a hole.
You see that?
No, I didn't see.
I'm gonna shoot that.
I mean, they know we're here.
All right, I shot one wall.
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared to go through you.
I'm actually scared.
Yeah, I can't break this.
I'm trying to break the sensor.
Oh, I see him.
She's on B.
I see someone on B.
Oh my god, we got I got plant.
You have to put you have to plant you have to plant
She's over there.
Okay, he's behind.
Okay, he's behind though.
He's right there.
Okay, I'm just gonna be I'm just gonna be okay I'm down I'm down he's on she's on the other side you can plant you can plant she can't she can't do anything Unless she starts pushing then she could do stuff.
Oh my god.
This is the longest plan of my life Moxie, I believe in you, Moxie.
You can game.
Oh, to the right?
He's got to go through the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah!
You like that?
Yeah, let's go!
Bob up and down?
Oh, my gosh!
Like a fish.
You're weaving and bobbing.
Literally.
You used your crouch.
Look at that.
Not even close.
It was 3-2, but not even close.
We'd let them have those two.
Oh my god, five.
I think it's because I shot the wall.
It's just shooting the wall.
Oh my.
You lose your accuracy when you just shoot walls.
I didn't know that.
Okay, that.
That was great bait.
Like, they're double looking at you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was thought.
Oh yeah, they were so confused.
They didn't know what to do.
They just saw me and they're like, what do we do?
The doggies in Maine.
We need all the pressure on her now.
I'd sacrifice my own body For the win I should get a medal of honor Literally Okay so apparently They're gonna be sending two people To each of our team So we don't know what I don't know if we could calm with them They'll just be doing their thing Two people okay It's gonna be a 4v4 And we're gonna get two people Each from TwitchCon We're gonna be live at TwitchCon Hopping into the game And playing with or what against us well we're they're well we're not going to combine our teams it's just two of us with two friends who got twitch time so and by the way if you guys see the qr codes on our screens guys you can scan that qr code right now to do a survey and thank you again a pubg for the sponsor yep yeah yeah yeah i assume we have to well this is actually really exciting i'm not a play demo yeah and hopping in with okay with us too yeah that's hype and like we're like literally being broadcast right now twitch i think i think i'm not sure i'm i assume our streams are playing at
twitchcon all right maybe guys everyone's at twitchcon watching hey hey hey mr hello hello yeah tag us like point at the screen and be like there they are we're we're on the winning team team we're the winners we're so smart no there was no key loss like i feel like our comms are down yeah yeah like we know what we're we know what we're doing we have we're like we're like playing chess right now we're thinking like 20 steps ahead we already know what's gonna happen in round three well i don't even know what's gonna happen in round three you gotta tell me no i can't spoil it we gotta keep it a secret we know yeah because we know we can't spoil yeah we can't tell them but we know that we win so that's that's all you know we know how the story ends yeah we know how the story ends it's all about the end the end game not the journey that's yeah that's what they say yeah exactly our game producer will also be joined oh can we have the game producer
yeah that guy sounds like he probably knows yeah he probably knows he probably knows how to play We should get the game producer.
We call dibs.
Oh.
No, you call dibs.
You actually call dibs.
He has a critical...
Because we want to learn.
We want to...
You know, we want to learn the game.
Yeah, exactly.
We want to learn the game.
Yeah, we're so passionate.
Those enemies are too...
They know too much.
We deserve...
Okay, I'll tell you, we love this game and we want to learn more from the game producer.
Wait, that's genius.
There we go.
He's got a, he's got to come to our team now.
Like, I even gave you a, yeah, you even gave me a vouch, a thumbs up.
Yeah, let me, I'm trying to find a nice emoji for this.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yep, I gave myself a thumbs up too.
He thumbs up to yourself, wall.
Yeah.
like sure they probably feel bad for us now and they'll give us the game producer anyways yeah exactly like damn wait they're thumbs up in each other oh boy they're in they're in they're in we just were missing one more okay we get like destroyed by someone on the defense team we know they got the game producer no all right two minutes they need two minutes oh what's your favorite far oh man i really like uh kayak okay oh the is that the guy with a camera or the uh yeah he's got the camera okay number one the guy in the camera wait is number one number one the game producer yeah you gotta be number one to the game producer they got the game producer we got
you yeah no we want you on our team yeah we we want you on it it's just guys guys come the game producer though the game producer okay so twitch con one is the game producer we should be able to swap like teammates yeah they should get the dokey uh you know players would you guys want to like in game exactly it's such a better experience you'll be able to you want to go against yeah you get a chance to kill me in game
she wants you out to go on the enemies well yeah she meant she meant uh yeah the people at not me yeah yeah yeah no moxie clutched it i mean do not see what moxie did last game like it's okay you're putting too much like you were obviously the the bait oh yeah yeah like it was a team effort you know without a base you wouldn't get the kills they were double looking at you exactly because i know you got we're able to like you got to get one go and it was not like the other yep all right they're ready i'm actually still really proud of myself for bobbing like that yeah that was insane that was actually really good you were like crouch spamming that all right i believe in us we have we have my fans i Believe in them.
Oh my god.
Wait, since they're at TwitchCon, they could like it would be so funny if like, you know, um You know the internet gets cut off on the other team Oh, yeah, if like if their PCs just turned off or something.
Yeah, guys, by the way, this is a joke.
Don't do that But I don't know what I mean It's not wait, they're like literally right next to each other.
Wait, they can screen they can screen chat you see it how do you see how do you see they posted a picture on the general chat do you see it they're literally next to each other they know guys hide your screens we can't tell them our chat okay i'm not gonna lie he stole kayak okay whatever it was he stole kayak hey hey we got beef hey how could you that's moxie's character yeah come on you knew i was a kayak man yeah Come on.
He literally said he was his favorite.
Wait, number three?
I don't know how number three has played this game yet.
But he's already pinging waypoints.
He's got strats.
Oh my god, he's strats.
He's like, go through here and then we win.
Oh my god, is there voice?
Yeah, there is, but I...
Yeah, I don't think we can feel each other.
Wait, we should send them first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Send them in first.
Yeah, we wanted you to...
Yeah, dude, this is...
You know?
Go in, guys.
You guys got it.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh!
I'm staying still!
Because I wasn't expecting my son to get shot at!
Point.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
I'm 1 HP.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
The Twitch squad, no, three.
I'm telling you, this guy's good.
I'm going the other side, I'm thinking.
I'm literally one, so I have to flank.
I'm going as well.
Frag out.
Wait, I can breach this.
Are you ready?
Okay, I guess you just shoot through it.
We're ready.
I'm going to breach.
I'm going to sacrifice my life, right?
Three, two, one.
Three, three, one, dated.
Go in.
Get the producer.
Okay, you...
Producer down.
We did it.
No, number three, like, this guy was out.
Yeah, like...
Number three was game.
one.
Okay, he insta-locked kayak.
Like, he knows.
He knows it's good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's been watching.
There you go.
Oh, apparently.
Oh, wait.
Does someone not get in?
Wait, did we kill three or four people?
I know.
We killed four.
We killed four?
Oh, so it worked.
Okay.
It worked.
You go Dragon number three.
Alright.
Same plan.
There we go.
Wait, someone in my chat said TwitchCon 03 is Shroud.
TwitchCon?
Oh, no.
No, there's no way.
No, I can see it.
I can see it.
Well, she's got to make sense.
Is this crowd streaming right now?
Like, playing.
It could be a run.
Oh, that's true.
He could have a rerun.
He had the, he recorded the stream in advance.
So he could come here and play with us.
Yep.
I mean, that's what the, that's what the birds were saying.
Wait, why is there three?
Wait, where is our fourth guy?
Where did he?
Where are you?
I'm on the other side of the map.
Oh, you're on the other side.
I mean, they won't know.
They won't know.
The long-ass flank of your life.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this is actually a genius flank.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They won't know.
Well, let me know when you guys are making noise.
We're making noise right now.
Our shield guy.
He's, like, doing his thing.
Okay.
All right.
Wait, why am I front-lining this?
This is not my job.
Oh, my God.
Our shield guy got hit.
That ain't good.
We're making noise.
By the way, you have the bomb.
Yeah, I'm already on A.
I'm on the site.
I'm dead.
Wait, Boxy, no!
I don't know!
Oh, no, Boxy, what happened?
What happened?
Okay, I was thinking you guys, like, had all four of them there.
They were two behind me.
Okay, yeah, it was not four.
It was absolutely not four.
Sticky bomb deployed.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm so nervous.
I got one It's me in I got two I don't know where the other two are But Twitch card number three is not doing so well Okay you get that How do we get to the other side We got breach There's a hole there's a hole there Yeah I'm breaching this I don't think they're gonna let us cross Alright I'm breaching cover me number three oh I'm gonna preach this to cover me oh my god he's one oh my god he's one he's actually one don't die don't die at the reload corner he's actually on your close right close right oh my god let's go oh my god you tea bag me let's go that is good that's good our defense time uh we just hate yeah haze was really good i'm gonna go haze i'm gonna grab med kit maybe we why don't we just get med kits bro i feel like you should go on a flank i'm telling you it didn't work for me yeah but i feel like it it would work it will yeah oh like we can't like yeah we're like defense imba barricade that's right what if we go out yeah okay bye for api what if i go so far away they
won't see me on the flank oh my god you're so true you're so right you're so right so wait until all of us dies and then you go in and exactly exactly that's genius okay i'm going to throw in a med kit sorry we're coming okay i'm lost i'm lost i'm lost i'm scared okay i'm scared i'm back i'm actually scared we barricaded everything what do you mean you can't be scared right now everything's barricaded no no i'm fine i'm fine in the mirror okay okay
barbed wires down setting wire okay i have med kits next to me but only next to me oh my god they're over there They're on me, they're on me!
I got one!
There's another one.
Oh my god, they have different angles everywhere.
It's okay.
I have a med kit.
Okay, that's not okay.
Oh my god, he's low.
Nice.
Where's the last guy?
He's on here.
Last guy on my hallway.
We got in cover.
We got, we just wait, we just make him wait.
Crossfire, crossfire, crossfire!
I swear to God, if he comes over here, we're a bit...
I'm gonna...
Yeah, yeah, Joe can that.
Oh my god, he's on!
He's on the...
It's up to you Moksy He's right behind you He's fighting in that wall He's fighting in that wall He might breach it Or he might He might say I'm actually so scared
Oh he's on top Oh come on Oh come on He thought he was sly Oh he tried a corner peek That let's go Oh my god Let's go We don't need the producer No we are not Producing We can stay on that Look at us.
We're gamers.
Oh, look at us.
W-O-4 for the bait.
Look at us.
Look at our accuracy.
Look at our detail.
Look at us go.
No.
All right.
We got to do.
SwitchCon 03 is low-key a natural.
Yeah.
Shopping a mall.
Yeah, we got TwitchCon number three.
And TwitchCon number four.
You were doing good too.
You're gaming.
All right.
Oh, we need to make a new code.
Okay, okay.
We leave.
Yeah, yeah, we leave.
Wait, actually, JK, we leave.
Don't join that one.
Left.
All right, here we go.
I got the new code.
Lower your rescue.
We got our shield.
Okay, okay, I'm joining.
All right, now we got the producer.
New people?
I actually don't know.
no are these new people i think so right
we'll find out we'll find out oh you know what i'll take this 5v2 i'll see yeah no no that was actually low-key fair i feel like that's very fair and balanced a 5v2 oh wait wait they got the producer again wait a minute wait the producer really doesn't want to play with us oh because we're We're challenged,
you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's like, he's like, oh, these guys are good.
I got to test my skills against them.
Mm-hmm.
All right.
We're just waiting on everybody, the TwitchCon people, to ready up.
But you guys have been joining the stream so far.
Why don't you do the survey that's pinned in our chat?
So you're scanning the QR code.
that's on screen guys while we wait you can do it a little survey and you can win a $50 chance to win a $50 steam code come on then that's free yeah that's practically free alright ready?
moxie I'm ready I'm ready oh I didn't ready up okay let's go
alright here we go
we're attack alright use a scope well i haven't even tried the scope oh wait there's a sniper oh yeah there is a sniper well i'm looking on dryer oh where is she i mean the hammer has not failed me yet i believe in the hammer camera drone a camera drone oh you can like fly yeah you can just like fly it around without going in that's got to be that's got to be op yeah they won't i feel like they won't notice they will the the game hasn't even come out yet so they won't know how to shoot the uh yeah no they won't they won't they won't yeah they'll just be like what's that noise oh is this like uh spectator is that like a spectator drone yeah it'll be like oh the chat's just spectating so they will not shoot it yep they won't now your brain is like a gun on this drone like can i give this drone like my pistol maybe why you tape a tape a gun on the drone wait where's our fourth person oh oh twitch got number four oh i hit him i hit him back wait where's twitch guy number two oh who's
scanning is that you scanning no I don't know there's is that them scanning us I'm scared yeah I'm Loki scared as well I'm scared what do they start thinking I'm not ready for that I'm never break these doors
yeah oh that's awkward oh wait a second drone grenade oh um we lost one we lost i mean we lost one before we got to break this chat do you need me there to breach scanning ahead i'm heading over i'm ready i mean b's open oh b is open oh oh you know i'm here oh that's crazy oh my god what's that oh my god what's the guy what's I'm not expecting that guy over there.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
He's got me in the corner.
I'm baiting this other guy.
There's this other guy on my ass right now.
Oh my god, he's one.
He's one.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's actually one!
He's flanking?
Yeah, he's flanking.
No, he's coming back.
He's walking back.
But he was one HP.
that's twitch god number one he's one hp grenade out oh my god you're both one oh my god oh my god oh my god i had him i had him i don't know it's 10 seconds we aren't breaching anything um oh they were all over there they were just wait they sent the wait they sent the has meat shields that's messed up they're sending them as intel they sent them as intel well they can't that's we triage which cotton plays as a team as a team like a member of the team dude not a meat shield yeah exactly yeah i'm gonna run with the shotgun the sniper was not ideal there oh yeah it was just i feel like everybody plays so close quarters
maybe we gotta be more communicative let me let me draw drop of waypoint.
Yeah, drop of way.
Wait, you're not with us, Mozzie.
Oh boy, you're not with us now.
Sorry, I wasn't with you.
That was my bad.
I'm just drawing random arrows.
It's the same pathway.
It's like, it's like a little Google Maps.
I only can place up to eight waypoints.
Alright.
That's our little Google Maps.
Okay, to be fair, we started off punching each other.
like it did not start out well.
I walk in front.
Oh, they're going to punch each other.
Oh, no, they're working.
Yeah.
They're actually way better than me.
What the hell?
They're so much more.
Oh my God.
Oh, we lost both of them.
We are.
I'm running.
We have two minutes to work with.
Wait, but the bomb is on the other side.
They dropped the bomb.
Yeah.
They're all on the bomb.
We got to just get weird.
We got to get weird.
Oh, you're right.
Wait, wait, I can't.
I'll make sure we don't get flanged.
wait wait you oh they foam walled it wait i'm gonna i'm gonna shoot the foam wall so they'll think we're still there and then oh you see that nice where i'm gonna go behind you don't know i got him i got him the other one's on me one close i'll go i'll go no oh yeah me killed me I'm so,
I was half HP.
There was nothing I could do.
I could have killed, no, I could, that was my bad.
That was half HP.
You know, we got three, we almost got three by ourselves.
Like, our team, they sold, they sold.
They sold.
It wasn't us.
All right.
I'm going, I'm going, yeah.
I'm going, Hayes.
I feel like, Hayes has been working, you know, yeah, exactly.
You know, they got the producer now.
The producer's locking in.
The producer's backseating everyone.
like you know like okay hold this angle like yeah yeah exactly here can i oh wait no i can't i'm just gonna put wires here all right goodbye setting wire setting wire oh yeah and then barricade tab i'm barricading myself inside this point which is very scary i barricade myself within the point
Well, I'm literally hiding By one of the entrance doors
Nope, they're going They're going a far way around Oh, oh my god Oh my god, they're both low Oh my god, I'm an idiot That's what happened What happened?
Oh, they're both low They're both very low Oh my god, oh my god, we can't get out of here Oh my god, we barricaded ourselves So we can't get out This is bad.
How do I get out?
How do you get out?
How do we get out?
Oh, they're breaking the doors.
They want to go A.
Maybe.
Oh, no.
Or they're breaking something.
Hey, um, TwitchCon 4, you break the door.
We gotta get it.
How do we get out?
We lock this.
That's how we get out.
Oh my god, there's nothing I can do.
I have a shotgun.
Oh my god.
This is bad.
Oh, the door name!
Oh my god!
They threw so many nades!
They threw...
Oh, no.
There was...
We locked her, so I didn't think the other Twitch chat person was going to be in there with me.
I thought I was just locked myself in.
Oh, no.
Look, I will say, they did throw 20 nades at me.
I don't think...
I've seen that.
I don't think I would have lived.
Alright, apparently we do Team Deathmatch back in.
Oh, the...
But I feel like they just got so lucky there, no?
Yeah, they got just so lucky those three rounds.
Yeah, exactly.
It was just luck.
They just, like, it was timing, you know?
You were still setting stuff up.
Yep.
And, you know, they caught me in my pants down, bro.
Yeah, exactly.
They caught me.
They were going to do a bathroom break, and they, how, that was so rude of them.
Just shooting you while you're in mid-pee.
Literally.
Like, what happened to etiquette, you know?
Yeah, wait.
I love the sportsmanship.
What happened to that?
It wasn't very smart me to lock myself.
I got new people on for 03 and 01.
Yeah.
It's time to swap.
Were we playing with the same team or are we swapping?
I don't know.
I'm waiting until I'll ask, are we playing same team or swapping teammate?
Wait, it sounds like you type really fast.
I had to like delete my message.
no but you were like oh yeah my wooden keyboard the gamer keyboard yep i'm just waiting until oh last game we're trying to give everyone an equal chance to play with us guys trying to give everyone I'm waiting for them to reply Both myself and the dev are going Oh two staff members are coming in now Oh I guess they swap They want the smoke instead Yeah yeah yeah I swear I feel like the producer locked in After that first game against this He's like okay okay they're not playing wrong Yeah yeah they're not they're not messing about We gotta we gotta actually mess them up And he was right.
Yeah, no, we got messed up for sure.
We got messed up.
No, he messed us up.
Real good.
I don't even know what to play.
I forgot what character I was on.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
Oh, I haven't played.
This is the last match, by the way, Moxie.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try.
Thank you.
Oh, they have a drill camera.
One of them's deep main.
Oh, my God.
I could be the producer.
What is going on, guys?
I'm doing the longest flank of my life just to die, I'm pretty sure.
I still wear it.
I gotta swap the gun.
I literally have not seen anybody.
I did the longest flank of my life and saw no one.
Oh, there's...
That way?
Is that Mission up Oh my god I'm so paranoid right now I'm so paranoid Oh my god Oh my god I was not expecting that Nade Wait Nades are so OP
Wait can I shoot Oh wait I can't shoot from me Oh my god
Oh my god You're going crazy.
Wait, I wanted to shot me through the wall.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
You can wall bang it.
Oh, God.
I got scouted.
Wait, you can't shoot through that.
I even crouched it.
Frag out.
Oh, my God.
They got crossed on me.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
I'm just gaming.
Oh, my God.
TwitchCon 03 just juked me.
hard oh my god he was doing circles oh it's not ready for that wait what wait oh what they finally find me he just killed you he killed me i was like what i got friendly yeah unlucky oh Wait, we're like so close too Yeah, that was it.
This is a close game.
Oh my god.
What the hell is he doing there?
What is he doing there?
He was trying to hammer you.
He was trying to hammer you
He really said hammer down
He's always one in the middle to your left.
Oh my god.
No, I'm getting shot by someone else I'm I'm oh no, I got shot by a someone behind me.
I couldn't finalize your kill.
I just shot my teammate.
Oh, there's someone hiding.
They're playing.
They're hiding.
Oh my god.
Oh god, I got flashed.
I got flashed too.
I'm flashed bad.
Wait, I think he flashed himself.
Are you serious?
I couldn't get him.
Oh my god.
Wait.
They shot I got shot at in different time.
I'm changing my camera.
That's it.
No more manual camera.
I made sure I've been playing on auto camera.
It's even game.
It's no longer even.
Oh, it's even again.
I just got hammered.
Oh my god.
I just got hamburger.
I just got hammered dad They got the win off that No Oh my he slammed my head Oh, no Oh, that's good.
Oh, I'm gonna get a clip.
Oh, no Can someone clip that because someone they can't wall up?
You got hammered.
You got smashed.
Hammered down.
I got actually smashed in.
You got smashed in.
That's crazy.
Jeez, Louise.
It bonked, bro.
That was fun, though.
I really like the sniper lady, buddy.
Yeah, oh, was the sniper good during death match?
During that map, there was like longest hallways ever.
That's true.
TwitchCon number two, thanks for carrying our asses.
Sorry, we got bonked.
Yep.
GGs, GGs, everyone.
Thank you again to PUBG for the sponsor.
You guys see, if you guys can check out that survey that's pinned in both our chats and also the QR code.
Fill that out because it does help out the stream a lot.
And you can check out PUBG Blindspot on Steam.
added to your wish list and a keep up to date with the game yeah yeah yeah yeah wish list that game right now we're gonna say oh we're done yeah we oh my god did you see the other day they left instantly and we're still here look at that see we I was ready to keep going yeah yeah we yeah exactly we won the vibe We might not win Team Deathmatch.
We won the Vibe Squad.
They got carried by their Twitch Conners.
Yeah, exactly.
They got carried.
It wasn't them.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, look, look.
Okay, and also like Enfant, but like, look.
Yeah, maybe a little bit of them.
Maybe Enfant carried a little bit.
But like, we did our job as a team.
Everyone did equal on our team.
Yep.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
That's it.
Yeah, GG's, Mox.
It was fun playing with you, man.
No, it was fun.
It was a lot of fun.
Yeah.
I'm down anytime when this game comes out.
I'm down.
Yeah, I'm down too.
I'm down any other game any other game that I see you in I'm down.
Hey, I'm down too.
Just hit me up.
I'm down.
Yeah.
Yeah GGs later later later.
Bye.
Bye bye.
Bye bye Hi everyone.
That's so fun.
I had a lot of okay, we might have sold a little bit, but look we we were having a good time Wait, wait, we might have sold.
Okay, I didn't get it.
I, you saw me bobbing and weaving the hammer kills, okay?
I was like, I'm not dying by the hammer.
I rather die by the gun than the hammer.
Like, you saw me running away to a bullet.
At least I didn't get hammered.
I feel like I should, I think like, um, the auto camera was better during deathmatch.
than it is for um for manual manual was good i think manual was good for uh for uh search and destroy um because like i was able to keep the camera where i wanted it to keep but like team deathmatch i had to use the auto one was actually it fell a lot better i should have kept that auto in the beginning for team deathmatch um but it was great time shout out to pubg again for the sponsor uh hope you guys check out pubg blind spot um had a great time playing with moxie um um he was uh mpin was gaming like he's a pro player um so he was doing so much like we were i was like oh my god
he was actually pretty scary um playing against him um but moxie and i we uh yeah he's a natural uh uh he play he plays pro in his game of choice um but i had really fun playing with moxie like we might not be pro players but we held our own we did some cool ass okay we also said thank you for the raid you did so well too um your duo was so scary to play against um like he was headshotting
We clutched it, Moxie and I?
We were doing some clutch shit.
we were both, we were both doing some crazy shit together.
Yeah.
We got some gamer moments.
But, like I said, thank you again.
It does help a lot if you guys can do the QR code and stuff like that.
I mean, it was fun.
I had a lot of fun playing with...
uh um playing with moxie uh and um and okay i got shot by my own team it's all right well moxie i didn't shoot each other we didn't shoot each other but we got shot in our back so we had shot um and uh yeah it was really fun playing with moxie and i hope we get to play do something together again that's not a sponsor i know i didn't kill him i didn't kill him i didn't kill them once uh we only hit each other we only smack each other with our pistols we don't need to actually smack each other but that was well he smacked me um when we were trying to breach he was smacking me when he was trying to breach um but yeah we gotta check out this game i really don't really know what else to say i think moxie might still be sure i'll go raid him um I don't know if he's still streaming or not so I'll check it out I don't know what he's planning on playing after uh I don't know so but but but I'll go raid him too because I don't know what I'll be doing later today so I'm gonna use this to sorry
sir I know he just raided me but I know he just raided me uh but I'm gonna head off now too I'm raid moxie but thank you all for coming thank you and pubg for the sponsor please feel free to check it out it's a top down a tactical shooter you see that we all had a lot of fun um a lot of fun today um and i hope people at twitch con had a lot of fun watching us and people at twitch con had fun playing with us too i hope you guys all had fun um anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and we're around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for am I going to stream later?
Maybe.
I'm not sure yet, but I'm going to go raid Moxie now.
But if I do stream later, I'll let you guys know.
I didn't have any plans.
I didn't know what to stream later today because like I said, I went straight to bed yesterday night.
So like I was also, I just don't have any idea what I'm going to be doing later.
But if you want to check me out, for those who don't know me, my name is Dokibert.
I usually stream on YouTube.
Today I'm on Twitch because it is a sponsor today.
And usually some of my sponsors go to Twitch.
You want to know a stream on Twitch.
Please feel free to check out my Twitter and follow me there because I usually tweet out whenever I'm getting sponsored or like whenever I'm streaming on Twitch.
If you want to support me via other means, feel free to check out my merch.
Exclamation point merch.
Exclamation point socials.
Exclamation point.
I mean, social has everything.
But yeah, hey guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.
Thank you all for the follows, bitties and love today.
I appreciate it.
time playing with the dragons too i didn't say dragons when i was like oh we're playing chat because i don't know moxie was like what the hell is dragons like that's why i was like oh we're playing with my chat because i didn't want him to be like what the fuck is our dragons i'm trying to like you know use words that he like you won't think i'm weird as like a fleshy you know I feel like flesh.
I'm not embarrassed of you guys.
I just didn't want the flesh tuber to think like be like What's because like you know, they'll think like they'll think gooner and I'm like no no it's the I didn't want to I don't want to do a whole spiel about what vtuber culture I I didn't want to do a whole speech about vtuber culture like we had very limited time guys We had baby Hey guys I'll see you guys later everyone Bye everybody Don't hate you
I'm kidding Thank you for the 100 bitties Thank you You ain't You ain't putting this on me Guys anyway we're rating Moxie I'll see you guys later Bye bye